yeah hello everyone
how are you doing uh welcome back let's
see some
analysis of the game that i consider um
yeah let's be fair one of the best
preparations i had in the
air things master tournament and uh
i've tracked i've tried to uh crack any
publishes defense somehow like um
in many games but was not successful
that much
as i was very close in some games and so
on
but actually it was really really hard
he was playing the same system
all over again and i did it as well it's
white
so um this time again i started with
knight f3
c5 c4
knight c6 and now this
slightly strange looking move e3 but the
point is that anyway we're fighting for
the center so the point is that if
black goes let's say for g6 here then d4
and knight is kind of awkward on c6
because after let's say bishop g7
there's d5
and the structure is like reminds of the
king's indian but with
slight differences for example if black
goes knight t5
then there is take takes and i don't
know some e4 knight c3 bishop d3 and
white is kind of faster here also you
have to do something about the bishop on
e5
um standing quite strange there on e5 i
mean
after f4 is attacked and you don't have
too many
too many ways to um
you know to kind of uh save it rather
than bishop g7
like d6 maybe something then like bishop
g7 somewhere
but it's still already slightly worse
because white is kind of controlling the
center
and undermining the center is quite hard
as well here so
in a game nippon she was not never going
on this
um he was always going for let's say
here e3
he was going for knight f6
especially that he was kind of doing
okay with it so knight c3 e6
i think in the game and european team
championship russia against azerbaijan
uh he played g6 here d4 and took there
played d5 we had a very um hard fight
there actually in that game and in tate
no part was slightly slightly better
than he made a
crucial mistake and miss some knight d6
you can see that game
um i don't know any of the size you can
find that
so yeah so he didn't want to repeat this
line
he was always going for uh knight c3 e6
here
just challenging the center with d5 next
and
let's consider a kind of classical
system against what i was playing this
english stuff so
e6 d4
g5
yeah cdxd5
knight xd5
guys you can hear me well right i can
see the chat but
can you hear me well is it okay
guys since the voice fine i just can see
that somebody said there is no
no sound or something okay it's good
yeah
so um yeah knight takes d5
bishop d3 bishop e7
a3 i've played this as well against jan
in some other tournament
of the series of this rapid events and
um
here he went for castle short which is
considered kind of
um not that great uh because there is a
little trick of
knight takes d5 then the pawn takes on
c5 and there's queen c2 attacking h7
and the point of a3 in this case is that
there is no knight before never
so black probably has to take already
with the queen on d5 which is kind of
awkward
then there is queen c2 possibly um we
have played the game like this attendant
in a draw but he had a really tough um
end game with a lot of problems so
here he goes for c takes d4 once again
um yeah sorry a3 he goes for c takes d4
which is the natural reaction uh it
takes d4
castle short
castle short we're
repeating our game from one of the uh
from one of the rounds there in the
knockout stage
in our match so castle short b6
and here i prepared some kind of
interesting stuff so i went queen c2 i
think we have played this position
already
he played knight f6 here i went for
bishop g5
and um i still had some kind of
advantage but certainly black is fine
here
like bishop g5 they go for h6
usually and it was played in our game as
well
then let's say take stakes and bishop b4
then d5 and all that stuff you can see
there
i mean the game was played so knight has
six through d1 instead
this is the the line i have prepared for
this game
to root d1
yeah and now the point of the of
d1 move is that d5 is now much stronger
certainly that the rook is there on
d-line
uh all of the threats are kind of more
tricky as well of course
but the main idea is that black has to
go for h6 now to avoid any bishop g5 and
d5 stuff
let's say for example if after rook d1
they go for bishop b7 which is very
natural
then white just can go d5 here
unexpectedly
and after e takes d5 knight takes d5
if queen takes d5 bishop h7 white is
winning
but if knight xd5 then bishop h7 king h8
and bishop e4 this is important
so and now
it's actually a very cool trick so
bishop h7 can get shade bishop b4
and now the only way to play for black
is knight a5
yeah and now bishop d5 take d5 queen f5
probably black is able to hold it
somehow with the
let's say g6 going into end game takes
takes
rook takes d5 but certainly it's in game
without the pawn so pawn down simply
probably possible to keep it but uh i
mean it's not everyone's cup of tea it's
really unpleasant
so certainly jan is not going for this
he possibly knows what to do against
this but he doesn't remember his lines
and that was the trick i've
tried to play on so he goes for h6 which
is the best move here
um h6 and now yeah i can see the youtube
chat lazy panda 19. yeah i do
so h6 d5
edx d5 95 knight takes d5 because queen
d5 again loses to bishop h7 this is
winning for white
so knight takes d5 queen takes c6
and he goes for bishop e6 probably
remembering some of his lines but
certainly also it's easy to find it
because i mean
eight is hanging d5 is hanging next move
is bishop before something
and certainly black has to defend the
knight on e6 and now there is a
very kind of funny looking move but uh
actually quite strong this queen a4 so
the point is that
there is still a pin on the d line and
um
you can always go for bishop e4 and
stuff like trying to pin the knight
also queen can come to e4 so potentially
creating some kind of threats on the
king's flank
beside it white can just go for bishop
between rook c1 trying to pretend that
they're slightly better in the middle
game
also pressing a7 not letting the rook
out here
and so on black has to be quite precise
here
and the best move in this position is
queen d6 according to the engines
which is not that easy to make that's
what i saw in my preparation
uh because look i mean it's on the d
line quite strange because bishop before
was kind of threat also what are you
doing after bishop before is not clear
at the first side there is also one
other move for bishop c5 which is a bit
harder to make
um and then there are different ideas
that i had so i don't
really like to mention them here
certainly because maybe can be used
from time to time as well but um another
way for black to play is bishop c5
which is also kind of tactical a bit in
nepal style maybe
but you have to understand what you're
doing against bishop c4 let's say
you have to foresee some kind of queen
e8 here
which is uh it's kind of tough to find
let's say i mean there's also queen c2
but there is queen eight
and now you have to know that rook f
takes e8
bishop d5
rkd8
so there is some kind of before let's
say bishop is 7 bishop takes h6
with the pawn up for white slightly
slightly better chances
and um finally it's a draw probably but
still black has to know it but also
after bishop c5 there are different
possibilities for white
uh one of them is like bishop f4 then
the suggestion of engine usually is to
sacrifice this play
let's say knight f4 which of h7 king h7
or d8
then knight h2 check and due to the two
bishops
and good rooks you know they're white
black is probably having enough
compensation here
but it's all very very much complicated
and so on
so um
yeah so this is the
more or less best ways to play for black
bishop c5 and queen d6
black still has to know his stuff but so
this is kind of
suggestion for black so jan is going for
quincy sand which is also very natural
he wants to avoid the pin on the d
line and he wants just to get rid of the
spin just bring the rook to d8 or c8 or
maybe disrupt to d8 and then the other
to c8 and queen to b7 or c6
play just a normal position but
certainly admits um
a strong reply by white which is very
very natural i've played here bishop d2
it's not the end of the world for black
but still it's already kind of awkward
because the queen is not feeling safe
there on c7 um rook is coming to
c1 and then there is like a lot of
threats with bishop a6
the knight coming to c6 and stuff so
it's kind of tricky for black already
i've played bishop i was quite happy
about my position because it's like
kind of catching your opponent on this
kind of line and he feels already
awkward um complex suggestions here is
like rkc8 maybe bishop to c5
but it's already kind of complicated
let's say it does through kc1 queen is
seven you have to see this move and
rookie 1 there is some rook ac8 i don't
know it still looks like
kind of awkward for black uh slightly
slightly better even if i play some kind
of
i don't know h3 or stuff like just
playing with calm
for company maybe it's fine but for for
the humanoids kind of tricky so it's a
bit unpleasant
and um certainly it's it was the way i
was
kind of preferring to play i prefer to
play this way
in this tournament around equality with
slight
chances to um to trick your opponents
and playing it's
kind of wesley so style quite safe but
uh with a lot of different
small small tricks and not much of the
risk
maybe it's not it's not the most
exciting chess you want to expect
you want the sacrifices uh five rooks
and ten queens
but it's not always possible and
certainly in such a tournament like
masters tournament
it's more important not to lose rather
than to win many games
so yeah i think it worked quite well the
strategy there
but i mean it worked once but uh twice
of course is not an easy story but we
will see we'll try to experiment with
different
uh different approaches so um
yeah after bishop d2 i think already he
got a bit confused
oh sorry i just moved the screen but
it's because of the
yeah it's fine now right
um so he went queen c7 bishop d2
and now he starts to make mistakes so he
goes okay d8
not the end of the world yet but already
quite unpleasant
okay 88 rkc one very natural for me
look at this pisses um harmoniously
placed
queen to e4 maybe knight and d4 and c6
and stuff okay c1
and of course uh jan has to go here
either queen d6 which is
not that natural or queen b8 which is
more natural
and of course i guess he was afraid
already here of knight d4
bishop d7 some bishop b5 let's be fair
we don't care much about the compass
evaluation here it's just slightly
better for white easier play
and some pressure without any risk so
which is
which is very fine for such a match
where every half point matters
and here i was extremely surprised
because jan is really
blundering i mean the pressure is high
and also the tension of course is high
and
you know the tiredness is telling from
time to time you have to control your
emotions as well it's
kind of complicated of course especially
that the match match is important so he
goes here for queen b7 which is a very
bad move
immediately um you know during the
tournament i'm trying to
uh to switch between the screens uh
there is one screen
that shows the the video of the players
and the other
screen is that um we're playing on more
or less
and uh there is a screen sharing so so
the arbiters can see the
can see your screens and so on so i was
changing from the video to
um to the to the playing
platform where we play and uh here on
the camera already i saw that something
is wrong with uh
jan's face there he's like kind of
not that much uh liking his position
feels it's a bit awkward and uh i also
played here queen
e4
and uh switched icing back to the camera
and just so that uh
he realized that he's completely lost
here and he's just moved 19 and it's
like
three moves after my preparation has
more or less ended
i did not expect 27 of course and um
yeah here i mean he was in can we call
it the chest knock down or something
he was really really upset about this
and um yeah so queen e4 the point is
that the queen is pinned here
knight f6 is now impossible to stop
queen h7 check
so black has just to give the pawn here
g6 was played
bishop h6 rook fe-8 oh sorry bishop f5
he played here
rook f8 is just uh yeah i mean okay
bishop b5 maybe just
claiming the rook there exchange
completely winning for white
so he went bishop f5 24
even though compy shows here that queen
e1 is just easier
not allowing any bishop e2 so bishop
distribution of a just clear exchange up
okay yeah okay i didn't see this so i
went queen a4
bishop d3 bishop f8
i thought it's completely winning bishop
b2
oh now compass suggestion is rookie one
it's probably
even easier i just played this because i
saw the penis there
seems to be quite easy bishop to sound
bishop d1 d1
queen e7 i was very happy about the spin
because pawn up g3 h4 i'll just move my
pawns um
just bring my team maybe rook b4 95 and
stuff
and in the game it was even easier
because you've played b5 now
position is completely lost for black i
went h4 very natural trying to at some
point maybe attacking with h5 and stuff
just uh
undermining the the king's flank spawns
and stuff
um yeah just just a normal move now he
went through d7
i went 95. the point of rook d7 is that
he wants to play knight f6
or knight b6 get rid of the pin so 95
from d6
um g3 because i didn't find uh the
direct way to win here even though
comp even says knight f3 back and route
d7 or key one is winning
okay it's way too complicated g3 just
fine a6
and i went knight g4 the point is that i
want to play knight t3 and then take on
d6
also knight h6 knight if six are in the
air
26 was the best defense here queen e6
and um
then maybe i can go for d3 trying to
play 93 game
and stuff opposition is very very close
to winning maybe i have to somehow to
regroup 95 to f3 or
else but it's very very close to winning
so after 94 he went through d7
queen e5 very natural rook d5 is
threatening now position is like
completely winning if black just takes
here 95 from d89 g4
uh with a lot of rook to xd5 knight f6
pins ids and 93 as well if king j73
white is completely winning so it's
easy and um
yeah i was already sure that i'm winning
here so he just went 26 it's a desperado
position is completely lost just had to
calculate a few things here
rook takes d5 and uh certainly
young resigned because he takes d5
knight f6 picking up the d7 rook
knight rook d5 is knight f6 king
wherever 95 it takes d5
i mean whatever now g4 f3 king to f2
and just picking up the spawn as i have
the advanced passer there
which is always winning also the pawn up
in the pawns and game maybe king of
funny two is even
easier so young resign was very very
important game